[Music]
cheers to cristian cásseres with his
news briefing in
spanish starting at midnight several
hobbit-related restrictions will
be lifted in work county the
capacity limit on sites will
now be 80 percent however
some  businesses still face
hiring challenges
to meet demand around the
country restaurant owners don't
have enough employees when they
close due to the pandemic many
employees find jobs at
different sites while others
receive more money by collecting
federal aid while  stay at home if you
're looking for a job i heard this the
cosmopolitan is hosting a
job fair on tuesday this will be from 10
am to 2 pm inside the
chelsea you must apply
online prior to the event at cosmopolitan
in las vegas'  dotcom
and if you haven't gotten the coronavirus vaccine yet, there
will be several
clinics  as open this weekend on
saturday they will be giving vaccines inside
the community center for price near
lake mead boulevard and christina line
from half past nine until three in
the afternoon they will also be offering the
vaccine at the martin
luther king retirement center  junior this will be from
nine in the morning until noon it is
recommended to make an appointment in advance for
more information you can visit
our news now dotcom diagonal page in
Spanish there you will find a
complete list of available jobs and
prepare for the hot
temperatures for this Friday
hit the high 90s and triple
digits hear this by the weekend
now the winds will be back tomorrow and
on sunday we will have a brief absence
from the heat for monday before the
temps rise again remember to
stay hydrated and don't forget the
sunscreen im  cristian casseres
with his informative test of news now in
spanish good day